today on the matt wall show as left-wing
activists stalk lawmakers and bathrooms
the fbi has been mobilized to hunt down
parents who raise their voices during
school board meetings because that's the
priority right now also facebook goes
mysteriously dark for hours as democrats
in the media ramp up pressure to compel
the company to further censor
conservative content and a new report
shows how the united states has the
strictest mask guidelines for children
in the entire world plus a trans
activist tries to get a fast food
employee fired for misgendering in one
of the most vicious cancel culture
campaigns we've seen yet we'll talk
about that and much more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well once again i find myself
in a hotel suffering
because i do not have my my pillow
products and i simply i've become very
high maintenance
uh when it comes to when it comes to the
things that i need to sleep and uh my
pillow i needed my pill price i don't
have them in the hotel and that's a
problem but the great thing about my
pillow is not only are the products
great but they also want to give back to
our listeners you can get great
discounts on all my pillow products if
you go to mypillow.com right now and
click on the radio listeners
specials get deep discounts on my pillow
mattress toppers towels and so much more
for example my pillow is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza sheets
they're top quality sheets that you will
love all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty go to mypillar.com and
click on the radio listener square for
the buy one get one free offer on the
giza sheets and use promo code dailywire
checkout or call
800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including pillows slippers the my
pillowmaster stopper and everything else
that's mypillow.com and enter dailywire
or call 1-800-651-1148
and tell them dailywire sent you that's
1-800-651-1148
we are now two days removed from october
3rd the day of the bathroom insurrection
against senator cinema a day that will
live in infamy it was an assault on our
democracy and our very way of life
it wouldn't be too far to say that it
was the worst attack on our nation ever
like pearl harbor and 9 11 combined
twice i'll always remember where i was
when it happened
and i fear that i'll i'll never be the
same
i almost died that day
at least this is what would be said
about the incident if it had been
right-wing activists harassing a
lawmaker in the bathroom but left-wing
activists are judged on a different
scale and the measurement on that scale
the measurements are quite simple to
read it goes like this whatever the
left-wing activist does
is okay
they must have had a good reason to do
it so when they stalked senator cinema
in a restroom filmed her as she went
into the bathroom stall and yelled at
her for not supporting a bite's agenda
it was shrugged off by biden himself
here is biden in a press conference
yesterday responding to the incident and
not exactly condemning it listen
mr president you're talking about how
you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two uh have been pressured over the
weekend by activists joe manchin had
people on kayaks show up to his boat tl
adam senator cinema last night was
chased into a restroom do you think that
those tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to
people who have secret service standing
around them um so it's it's part of the
process
oh yeah so you know one thing i take
from that is uh hey senator cinema
doesn't have secret service protection
standing around her hint
hint it's all just part of the process
he says it happens to everybody i mean i
would wonder who else has it happened to
really everybody gets filmed in
bathrooms
who else
maybe i shouldn't be surprised that the
creepy perv biden thinks filming women
in restrooms is part of the process
although i'd hate to know what kind of
process he's referring to exactly in
fact the left seems in general to have a
thing for costing women in restrooms one
minute they're defending a male sex
predator who exposes erect penis to
women and children in the wii spa locker
room and the next they're cheering
illegal alien activists for confronting
a senator while she's on the toilet
these people just really don't think
women should have privacy in the
bathroom at all they just don't they
don't believe that and not just in the
bathroom either she being confronted
cinema over the last few days has been
harassed at her home
in the airport
on a plane
everywhere she goes now they follow and
scream at her because she doesn't fully
agree with biden's spending proposals
the feminist website jezebel published a
piece yesterday
directly calling for more harassment of
the senator in the bathroom in a piece
titled absolutely bully kristen cinema
outside of the bat of her bathroom stall
jezebel writer ashley reese waves off
the criticism of these intimidation
tactics as pearl clutching and says that
it was quote just a few constituents
following their representative into a
large bathroom to air their grievances
oh well as long as the bathroom was
large then never mind
jezebel represents the view of many on
the left including in the media chris
kirsten powers cnn contributor tweeted
on monday referring to one of the
illegal alien harassers who said that
her grandparents had been deported uh
she said which is worse your
grandparents being deported or being
followed into a bathroom because you
refused to stop and listen by people
desperate for your help this is not a
trick question
oh i can answer that um
being followed into the bathroom and
filmed is worse
okay that's that's illegal behavior
deporting illegal aliens on the other
hand
is law enforcement
so on in one case the law is being
broken
and in the other it's being enforced
so not a trick question and also not a
hard answer
but as we've seen the left views the law
as a rather blurry and subjective line
and they have good reason to see it that
way i mean if they're acting on behalf
of their ideology
they know that they're empowered to do
basically whatever they want they can
film senators in the bathroom they can
show up with bull horns to people's
homes in the middle of the night
they can riot they can loot they can
assault police officers they can burn
police stations to the ground they can
wage a months-long assault on a federal
courthouse they can stop traffic
they can harass and assault random
pedestrians and people and vehicles
they're able to do all of this with
rarely any penalty penalty
and meanwhile in the midst of of all of
it
the fbi has now officially been put on
the case of conservative parents who say
mean things to school board members
attorney general merrick garland on
monday while left-wing activists and
illegal aliens were stalking a u.s
senator across the country
he issued a memo not about that but
rather directing the fbi
to protect school boards from imaginary
threats
the memo says and i'll read it it says
in recent months there has been a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation and threats of violence
against school board administrators
board members teachers and and staff who
participate in the vital work of running
our nation's public schools while
spirited debate about policy matters is
protected under our constitution that
protection does not extend to threats of
violence or efforts to intimidate
individuals based on their views threats
against public servants are not only
illegal they run counter to our nation's
core values those who dedicate their
time and energy to ensuring that our
children receive a proper education in a
safe environment deserve to be able to
do their work without fear for their
safety the department takes these
incidents seriously and is committed to
using its authority and resources to
discourage these threats identify them
when they occur and prosecute them when
appropriate in the coming days the
department will announce a series of
measures designed to address the rise in
criminal conduct directed towards school
personnel coordination and partnership
with local law enforcement is critical
to implementing these measures for the
benefit of our nation's nearly 14 000
public school districts to this end i'm
directing the fbi working with each
united states attorney to convene
meetings with federal state local and
territorial leaders in each federal
judicial district within 30 days of this
issuance of the memo these meetings will
facilitate the discussion of strategies
for addressing threats against school
board administrators board members
teachers and will open dedicated lines
of communication for threat reporting
assessment and response
now
just to be perfectly clear
there has been
no
violence against school board members at
all
the very small number of violent
incidents at meetings have been brief
scuffles between protesters where nobody
got hurt and that's on both sides okay
people on both sides of an issue show up
the conversation gets a little bit
heated
and uh and then there's a scuffle and no
one really gets hurt
as for threats and intimidation which is
the main thing he's focusing on
i've been at some of these meetings
where threats and intimidation allegedly
happened i mean i've been at the
meetings where the media reports ah
there's threats and intimidation
i've also watched videos of other
meetings where it supposedly occurred
and i have heard very little of anything
that could be accurately described that
way
mostly i've heard angry parents
expressing their point of view sometimes
raising their voice
god forbid but that's as far as it goes
and yet we're supposed to believe that
parents getting a little heated during a
school board meeting is some kind of
national security threat that requires a
federal law enforcement response
the fbi has done nothing at all in
response to blm and t for rioters
who openly harass and intimidate law
enforcement and civilians
often do much worse than that
but now they mobilize against parents at
school boards
as someone who's been accused of being
you know one of the ringleaders of this
school board movement i expect i'll
probably be on the fbi most wanted list
by the end of the week
and it's clear what this is really about
the fbi doesn't care about the
harassment of public officials not
generally anyway if they did the feds
would be tracking down cinema's
harassers and shipping their butts back
to mexico
i mean they are illegal aliens as they
confessed
no for all their talk about intimidation
this itself what the fbi do is doing is
an intimidation tactic
this is about intimidating parents
regular working class people
who've had the gall the nerve to speak
up against the system's indoctrination
and abuse of their children
the public school system is the factory
it's the assembly line where kids are
shuffled along and they're assembled and
packaged in the way the state wants
in order to make them ideologically
compliant vassals
but this grassroots
non-violent uprising of parents and
school boards has threatened that system
and exposed it and the powers that be
cannot allow it
what this means first of all is that the
law is dead in this country
that's not hyperbole it's dead it's been
the case for quite some time
when federal law enforcement is
mobilized against middle-class parents
who are upset at their school board
members
that's a sign one of the more glaring
signs but certainly not the only one
that there's no higher law in this
country beyond the whims and desires of
the elites the law is
don't upset or interfere with them
that's the only law
they recognize no other
but it also means on the positive side
that our work in these school board
meetings is having an effect
uh it's making a difference
which means now is the time to double
down not back down
that means keep showing up keep speaking
out
and i can tell you that's exactly what
i'll be doing
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a word from relief band did you know
that a third of americans regularly
suffer from nausea and i am one of those
sufferers it's just many one of the many
victim groups i belong to
also as a color-blind american
as an american who suffers from
allergies i have i have all those bases
covered but uh nausea is no joke and if
you're looking for a better solution to
keeping nausea out of your life you
gotta check out relief ben relief ben is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug free that also means
that there's no side effects it's
non-drowsy that's the best thing about
it i think and it's very effective
relief ban is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that's been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting and if you know
someone who deals with nausea or if you
deal with it yourself then you need to
get relief ban as the world's opening is
opening back up don't let the fear of
nausea keep you on the sidelines right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for my listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code wall
sure receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20 off
so uh just wrapping things up here in uh
wisconsin i'm in milwaukee right now and
we spoke at uh i was at wisconsin
whitewater university
yesterday and it was a great event
um great turnout
and and all all of that was all that was
wonderful there is this weird
you know coincidence i mean i'm sure
it's just a coincidence but i find this
very often in the uh speeches that i
give at universities uh very often they
end up having
um you know incidentally these weird
problems with their air conditioning and
so quite often i find myself in rooms
where uh you know there's 250 people
packed in there and the air
conditioning's not working and that's
what happened yesterday so the air
conditioning works really it's like the
weird thing is again totally i'm sure
it's just coincidence it's not a
conspiracy theory right how could i ever
uh imply that anything intentional would
be done
by the university because they don't
want me there but it is it's strange how
oh you know we can't get the the ac to
work in this one room every other room
around this room it works fine but yeah
this one it's real complicated we can't
get it on we'd have to go across
um
the campus we have to like climb a
mountain
and there'd be a troll we have to answer
some riddles and then go into a cave and
that's where the ac control is for this
particular room and we just can't do it
yeah i'm sure it makes sense
and it was but it was kind of funny on
the way so so
you know at the speech i'm i'm always
ready and and eager when i give these
speeches because we do the q a at the
end
and i'm always ready and eager to engage
with
any of the opposition
people who the people who don't want me
there especially the students
um they're always welcome to to come to
the events
and in fact uh you know if you if you if
you if you disagree with me and and then
then you could even get to the front of
the line in the q a in most of these
events
but especially recently
now i said recently i mean the last i
don't know year or so
um
they just don't show up they don't come
to the events and they especially don't
want to say anything in the q a but they
will stand outside so there was um
i guess the lgbt group on campus at uh
wisconsin whitewater they didn't want to
go to the event
um
they don't want to do that because they
didn't want to be subject they didn't
want their ears to be subject their
minds to be subjected to the scary
opinions
but they were outside they were actually
marching outside around the building
uh chanting i don't who knows what and
it just so happens
and i hate myself for this
i mean i was i was telling sean my
producer on the way on the way back that
i just like i i hate myself for not
taking out my camera and filming this
you know most people
these days their first reaction to
anything is to get their phone out and
start filming i have the opposite thing
where i never think to film i mean
aliens could actually land on earth and
i wouldn't even think to pull my phone
out and get it documented so on the way
out we were walking to our car and it
just so happened that the march the
march against me was walking by at that
exact moment so i was walking alongside
my own actually in my own protest march
for a good like 100 feet
to my car
it was just kind of funny
i tried to engage with them but they
they didn't want to engage all they did
was they just kept on chanting
all right um
let's uh start with this so facebook
went down yesterday mysteriously
very very odd timing uh
first of all for for a website like
facebook for to go down for hours i mean
this was like five or six hours it was
down
it's already pretty unusual i think this
is the longest outage facebook has ever
had i'm pretty sure but it happened
right when they were under attack from
the media and the left for not properly
suppressing conservative content
i haven't quite worked out what the
conspiracy theory should be for this
it just it seems intuitively obvious
that there must there's probably some
kind of connection i mean that's a hell
they have their worst outage
right at the moment when they're getting
the worst pr
uh interesting but i'm not i'll let
someone else fill in the blanks like
what is what's the connection let's
let's let's have fun with the conspiracy
there i haven't i haven't been able to
think much about that i haven't put it
all together but they facebook went out
and along with instagram and all their
other you know whatsapp and all the
other apps that they uh that they own
right as this as this pressure campaign
is mounting and there's going to be
testimony on capitol hill i believe
today about facebook
um
but we have to keep something in mind
like i said yesterday starting the show
in the opening monologue
a lot of conservatives
i'd say probably all of us
even if we use facebook
we're still not big fans of facebook
we're critics if i i certainly am a
critic of big tech in general
but the left when they're going after
big tech and going after facebook
especially
it's not for the same reason
so this this is not an enemy of my
enemies situation where we can link arms
together
and uh work on this project of trying to
take down facebook
and that was made obvious i mean if you
listen to what the media has been saying
about this it's very obvious here's just
one click clip this is msnbc and claire
mccaskill
talking about the problem that they see
with facebook yesterday watch this is a
personal opinion i think facebook is the
most maligned force in this country
other than crimes criminal enterprises
drug deals drug dealers gangs um or
obviously more malign than facebook but
the things that aren't illegal or
criminal i think facebook is the most
damaging
influence in this country and to say we
balanced you know the bottom line with
keeping our people together is absolute
hogwash do you think they'll be eating
up on capitol hill or do you think this
is still a blind spot
well first of all let's back the truck
up a little bit
congress when the internet began decided
they were going to make it the wild west
there was going to be literally no
regulation and in fact went so far is to
give all of these sites immunity from
anything bad that is posted on their
sites
now fast forward
the the internet has been an amazing
economic engine in this country but what
these all of these sites figured out is
that they track you they know what you
want to buy and that monetizes it and
for facebook and other sites if you're
afraid or you're angry you're going to
hang out more okay and when they talk
about afraid and angry they are talking
about right wingers that's what they
mean
that's what they mean when they say just
like when they talk about misinformation
hate speech all that all that it's just
all that means right-wing content and
all right-wing content
all right-wing content is automatically
misinformation angry hate speech uh
unsafe
etc and so forth
and that's also their interest in the
facebook whistleblower now
this uh this whistleblower francis
haugen
again talked about her yesterday she was
a former facebook employee
and now she's uh she and she was started
leaking internal documents
about the inner workings of facebook
and uh and then she had the the 60
minutes interview now she's going to be
on capitol hill
the media loves her democrat party loves
her
already you know it's just calling her a
whistleblower
is absurd to begin with
whistleblowers another one of those
terms that has really lost all meaning
a whistleblower is supposed to be
someone from within an organization
who's revealing
secrets
you know damaging secrets that are that
but but that are still relevant to the
public that we should know right
secrets about ways that organizations
are harming the public
now i don't doubt that facebook harms
the public but not in the ways that
these people
say but even but but
still what actual secrets has this
whistleblower revealed
the one thing she has is that um well
facebook knows that uh it's not good for
kids to be on instagram of course they
know that
everybody knows that
that's not a secret
that
anyone with a brain any parent with a
brain already knows that your kid
shouldn't be on instagram that's why i
put the onus on parents don't give your
kid the smartphone
so that that's that's the what else is
there like what what other information
has she revealed about
i don't doubt that there is
plenty of damaging information about
facebook that a real whistleblower could
reveal
but this is a fake whistleblower
and the fact that she's choosing this
that these are the the
the secrets she's telling these are the
skeletons that she's bringing out out of
the closet
there's one headline uh
about the whistleblower and it's the
headline was something like um
whistleblower reveals that
facebook uh
that values profit above all else or
something like that
facebook values profit
whistle whistleblower reveals oh my gosh
are you serious
this
multi-gazillion dollar behemoth cares
about profit i have no idea
glad we got the whistleblower on the
case
but there is a
now there are people kind of blowing the
whistle on the whistleblower so here's
the washington free beacon says the
facebook whistleblower who revealed
herself in a 60 minutes interview is
getting strategic communications
guidance from a top democratic operative
according to a source with direct
knowledge of the relationship which was
confirmed by another half dozen sources
with indirect knowledge of the
partnership francis halligan the former
facebook employee
um is working with the political
consultant and former oba obama admonish
administration deputy press secretary
bill burton
and his consulting firm bryson gillette
it is unclear when halgon's relationship
with burton and bryce and gillette began
how big her communications team is and
whether it includes other political
operatives but burton is now deeply
integrated with an immersion
infrastructure on left on the left
comprised of individuals and
organizations including the nonprofit
center for humane technology seeking to
press facebook to more aggressively
police political content
and then if you look at the executive
board of the uh this bryson gillette
organization which i have you see
nothing but
former obama administration officials uh
people who have worked on
elizabeth warren's campaign
okay nothing but democrat operatives
so she's got this
democratic operative firm this
democratic pr firm
that she's teaming up with
to reveal these secrets about facebook
that are not secrets at all
if it wasn't obvious by now what's
really going on here hopefully it is now
so i say again i understand that
conservatives don't like facebook
but you have to understand that the
corporate media is attacking them
because the corporate media wants to be
the sole gatekeepers deciding what
you're told and who tells it
so if if you are locking arms with them
it is to your detriment
a world without social media is a world
where the corporate media
once again controls almost all of the
information and determines which
perspectives are
heard so that's what they're pining for
it's the only thing they care about
i i am as you know critic of big tech
but but my criticism is from the
opposite angle
i want the companies to stop censoring
conservative speech
but the pressure right now is coming
from people who are mad they don't do it
more
which means again that this is not an
enemy of my enemy's situation where we
can join with corporate media to take
down facebook
because the the media wants to destroy
and silence you
not facebook
and they see this as an important step
in achieving that goal
it's it's crucial to draw this
distinction
so when i hear conservatives saying oh
you know what facebook went down
yesterday when it went down and
conservatives were out
it's better i hope it never comes back i
hope twitter goes down and never comes
back i i understand the sentiment i do
but you understand who that would
benefit most of all right
that's going to benefit the corporate
media
because these are their big competitors
for for the dissemination of information
and that's going to get rid of that
this is why they
this is why they hate facebook right now
because they know that people like me
can get out there and talk to you and
use this platform to do it there are
other platforms too but facebook is
still a platform where you can do that
um
so we just in our messaging and our
goals with uh with with social media
it's not that we're going to blindly
defend social media i know facebook i
love it they're they're they're angels
that's not it at all
they're major problems with facebook
but our criticisms are coming from
completely the opposite end here
we want entirely different things
all right um
you guys want to vomit
if you do it's uh you're in luck because
disney is making a documentary about
fauci called fauci
and uh here's the trailer watch
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see
he's funny weird and really playful
god help us
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast
it's affecting you now yeah
why
post-traumatic stress syndrome
when coveted hit he became this target
my dad said we're gonna get through this
whole thing and he's held that
you don't do it because you want to make
money you don't do it for the glory you
do it because you care when you're
involved in a race to stop a horrible
disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
i mean i i had to endure that so i chose
to make you suffer with me
uh
fauci
who has been nothing but but i mean by
anyone's standard
no matter where you stand on
covid and what the what the right
policies are and everything else
uh by anyone's standard
fauci has been an abysmal failure
going back to the to the aids epidemic
his entire career he has been a failure
it's it's hard you put anyone in
fouchy's position it's hard to see how
things would be worse right now
i can imagine them being better
i don't see how they'd be worse
you just you put you you take fouchy out
and put a i don't know
like a raccoon in that position
and uh you know a dead one roadkill
and i don't see how things could be
worse than they are right now
but this is this is the the glory of
being a bureaucrat is that no matter how
bad you do you're still you're still you
get to keep your job and sometimes
you're celebrated
as some sort of hero
but you see something like that and it
just it
it it sinks in yet again
how covid even though he's done an
abysmal job
in the face of of this crisis still
covet has been probably the best thing
that ever happened to him
and he absolutely loves the attention
which is why he's on he doesn't have to
be on tv every single day especially not
now
but but he is because he he loves it
and he's not the only one in a position
like that
who feels that way about it
all right uh
let's play another video that if if that
if that didn't get you hurling let's
play one more so this is from a a
preschool
and i'm not sure where the preschool is
but
here they are
encouraging the kids or forcing the kids
really to sing an ode to the mask
listen to this
two three
i
wear a mask to school
i wear a mask to school
hi ho the derry-o why we're a mask to
school
it helps to keep me safe
it helps to keep me safe
hi ho the derry-o it helps to keep me
safe
it keeps my friends safe
it keeps my friends safe
hi ho the derry-o it keeps my friends
safe and let me see a hooray put your
hands up in the air
[Music]
i think of course the kids aren't are
hardly even singing along they're just
totally confused
and that's how all kids that age
are reacting to all of this they have no
idea what's going on
they don't understand why they have to
wear the mask but but they do because
the adults around them are telling them
to
and uh and it keeps them safe
until it starts to really settle into
their minds
and they get to the point where
you know they're they're afraid not to
wear the mask
and that's and that's when you know
you've done
the permanent damage to them potentially
i mean
none of us can really imagine what it
what it must be like for these kids
because none of us have been
in
none of us had to deal with this when we
were this age
i mean there are quite a lot of things
that kids
little kids that age these days have to
deal with that none of us did
you think about the assault that's
underway against their basic sanity
we we didn't have that
and it's not like we didn't have uh
transmissible diseases
when we were kids
we had transmissible diseases that were
more threatening to us than cove it is
to these kids
like the flu
never any conversation about wearing a
mask
um so that
along with this attack on their identity
through the gender ideology i mean these
these are what these kids are are
dealing with every single day and it's
just it's impossible for us to to see
the world through their eyes
um
and to understand to really understand
what it's doing to them psychologically
but we know that it's nothing good
so i'm not sure five years from now 10
years from now
what state are these kids in
where it has been drilled into their
minds every single day
that
and they you know they can only
understand things in a very simple in a
very simple way
and so for them what they're being told
is that the air is dangerous
and i don't want to directly breathe the
air because i might die
um and i don't want to directly breathe
around other people i might kill them or
they might kill me
and this is drilled into their heads
even in the form of these cultish
sing-alongs
every single day
even when the mask thing goes away if it
ever does
what effect does that have on kids where
are kids psychologically after that
well we have no idea they're they're
guinea pigs so we'll check back in ten
years and see what kind of damage it did
them
whatever it is we know it's going to be
pretty significant
and related to this from the new york
post it says the united states the
united states is a strict mass guidance
for kids goes against policies across
much of the globe the u.s centers for
disease control and prevention
advises masking for all school kids two
and older that's earlier than the world
health organization european union union
and united kingdom
a professor of medicine at stanford
university said kids need to see faces
youngsters watch people's mouths to
learn to speak read and understand
emotions he said
we have this idea this is this again is
from this professor
we have this idea that this disease is
so bad that we must adopt any means
necessary to stop it from spreading
it's not that masks in school have no
cost they actually do have substantial
costs
now i seem to remember
someone making this exact point at a
school board meeting in a speech
about how kids need to see each other's
faces and they need to see their their
teachers faces and and see their lips
moving moving in order to learn to read
and to speak properly
i remember someone making that point oh
yeah i think it was me
and i was told that this is
anti-scientific that it's absurd that
it's a that it's a conspiracy theory
and yet this is exactly why
most countries around the globe are not
putting masks on kids at this age
the uk no longer advises masking for
students or staff at all
england recommends against masking for
anyone younger than three for health and
safety reasons
the european center for disease
prevention and control advises masking
when feasible for those older than 12
but recommends against masking for
primary school students
the who
advises children five and under should
never be required to mask
the u.n agency says well this is based
on the safety and overall interest of
the child and the capacity to
appropriately use a mask with minimal
assistance
and so those are
countries around the globe
uh health organizations
and yet
if you here in america
were to say what the world health
organization says
or to you know side with the
public health authorities so-called in
any other nation
around the globe
it'll be tagged as misinformation
because because apparently we are human
beings right it turns out and our kids
are human beings
and i know that's something that hasn't
dawned on a lot of leftists especially
but our kids are human beings and as
human beings you know there's more
there's more to your existence than just
your physical safety
there's a lot more that goes into life
and there's a lot more that needs to be
protected and fostered
and so when you say the only thing that
matters is just physical safety and
that's it
you're you're making a choice
you know you're making a sacrifice and
obviously that sacrifice is not always
going to be worth it
all right um
i don't know if you uh care about this
story at all but we talked briefly about
the controversy surrounding the ravens
in their game against denver on sunday
when they were up by two scores with
three seconds left in the game and
rather than take a knee and end it they
ran for another play to try to get an
nfl rushing record anyway people
especially in sports media this has been
a topic of conversation
and um people have been very mad about
this and so is denver's coach vic fangio
who
if you don't follow football you might
not realize that this is this is very
rare for a coach to say what you're
going to hear him say attacking another
coach in this way and in these terms but
here's what he had to say about that
listen to this
did you have a problem with the last
play that baltimore ran and yeah i
thought it was kind of [ __ ] but i
expected it from them
you know i've
37 years in pro ball i've never seen
anything like that so
but it was to be expected and we
expected it
why did you expect it from them because
i just know how they operate
you know they
that's just their
you know mode of operation there player
safety is secondary is that something
anybody even really talked about that
they had 42 straight or whatever the
number was 100 yard games and uh we
didn't talk about it during the week but
i'm sure the players were aware of it
you guys made them well aware of it
that's just embarrassing imagine being a
a professional head coach and you're
crying on camera
because you lost to another team and
they weren't they weren't merciful
enough with you
but i see this as part of the trend and
you see it in football
you see it probably in every sport
football's the main one that i follow so
i can speak to that but
we're we're taking the competitive
little by little
you're chipping away
from the competitive spirit
of the sport
so now it's a it's a
a controversy
if an nfl team
is they just they play football game is
60 minutes
they played for all 60 minutes
and they when you're on the football
field the objective is to gain yards and
so
uh
on your way to scoring points and so
they tried to gain yards every play that
they had the ball which which again is
the objective of the game
and people getting very upset about that
well it's not it's not nice to it might
hurt their feelings think about all
those professional football players on
the other side of that ball or
played paid millions of dollars to play
a child's game
you're really hurting their feelings
make them feel bad about themselves
little by little we chip away at the
competitive spirit and this
is happening at the younger levels
especially but also at the professional
level
which is a problem because
this is
the
the value of sports
one of the one of the primary things
that makes it valuable and worthwhile
is um
you know fostering a little bit of that
healthy competitive spirit
and it is a you know it's a it is a
controlled
environment for people to be competitive
and to
you know try try to try to win to try to
strive towards a goal
it's a good thing to teach kids
you know how to be competitive with it
within the rules
you have the rules here's the objective
of the game
here here's here's another team they're
going to try to stop you from achieving
that objective
and
try to go achieve it anyway
so you learn not only how to be
competitive you learn about being about
perseverance
many many many many great things come
from this
sports can be very valuable to society
in that way
but we're taking it away little by
little all right let's get now to
reading the comments
[Music]
[Music]
taylor crawford says chasing someone
down and confronting them in the
bathroom is middle school middle school
level immature
but i would say it's worse than than
that uh it's far worse than immature
it's again it's illegal and somehow that
that the fact that it's illegal to
film someone in a bathroom
against without their consent
that has somehow been lost in this
conversation that
we haven't even been asking that are we
gonna are these girls gonna be charged
with a crime because they did commit a
crime
um
bulim says if matt's producer sees this
make matt a discord account and make him
review scott's server
i don't know what that means i don't
know what any of those words mean well i
know matt i know what that means but the
rest i know
uh mr x says if no one has land rights
what made it theirs in the first place
how could it be stolen
right well that's that's
one of the many reasons why this claim
about america being on stolen land is
totally absurd
i mean
this this who who does this whole plot
of land that is the continental united
states who is it supposed to belong to
exactly
and why then
as i always say with these things the
the the entire globe every inhabited
inch of the globe
with the exception of
antarctica
right
uh
which is not inhabited so everywhere
else where there are people
it has been fought over and bled over
and that's the way the globe was settled
that's the way the lines were drawn
and that's the case everywhere you go
because for
thousands of years
how did you determine who who's
whose land it was
well if you could take the land then it
was yours
and if you could defend it then it
remained yours
if you couldn't take it then it wasn't
yours and if you couldn't defend it then
it wasn't yours
that's how these things were settled so
that's really the answer to the answer
to the question who has the land rights
well whoever could take it and defend it
had it that's it
and that's the rule that everybody
abided by
and you know what it's it's still the
rule today
i mean if china decides they want to
invade the united states and we're not
able to stop them and they just take it
over
i don't i don't quite see that happening
yet we're not quite at that point
maybe sometime in the future
unfortunately
but if they do then then then they do
they just they take it we could sit
there all we want and try to appeal to
some
higher authority which says that this
land is supposed to belong to us
but practically speaking it belongs to
whoever can take it
that was certainly the way of the world
for thousands of years
certainly the way uh native american
tribes functioned
and even today
although we feel insulated from some of
these realities some of these more
brutal realities of life
that insulation is mostly
a figment of our imagination
and it's a lot more tenuous than we
think
thomas says matt on the cell phone
discussion i think that a broader point
i heard this past sunday applies
maybe we stopped disciplining our kids
around the time that we stopped
disciplining ourselves
yeah and we talk about the fact that
kids are allowed to be on their cell
phones and parents give cell phones to
their kids and let them play on their
cell phones all day uh yeah that's an
important
point here
and that's one of the big reasons why
parents do this is because the parents
themselves
want to be able to be on their phone
you know that's that's probably the
primary motivation
i think it's it's two things for parents
that you know will give a smartphone
with internet access to their 10 year
old there are two things that motivate
one is well it's just what people do and
you know it's what all his friends do
and the other is hey i want to be able
to watch tv or be on my phone
and if my kid is that means not
bothering me
so
i think you're exactly right about that
and elf princess says matt i'm going to
counter your tie complaint with two
words high heels yeah i don't buy that
sorry elf princess
because you don't have to wear high
heels i don't want to hear complaints
about high heels
that's true i don't i don't envy that at
all
i don't understand even in terms of
physics how that works how you walk in
those does doesn't it seems to defy the
laws of science but you don't you don't
have to when was the last time you're at
an event where you had to wear high
heels
okay it no you go if you have go to a
formal event
the rule is you have to wear some kind
of formal
foot attire but you have many options
and that's the privilege that women have
they have many options for what they can
wear in these kinds of situations for
men
yeah we could wear just normal dress
shoes but we have to wear the suit we
don't have that choice
we do not have
bodily autonomy
in those situations
okay so we are the victims that's my
point well this podcast is brought to
you today by another podcast and that is
the jordan harbinger show listen if
you're sick and tired of
the subpar slop that passes for most
podcasts today including especially this
one that i'm recording in a damned hotel
uh then you gotta check out the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast that you
should definitely check out since you're
a fan of high quality fascinating
podcasts hosted by interesting people i
can only assume you're a fan of those
kind of podcasts i don't really know
because you're watching this show after
all the show covers such a wide range of
topics through weekly interviews with
hard with hard-hitting guests and there
are tons of episodes you'll find
interesting since you're a fan of this
show i'd recommend our listeners check
out his episodes with brian keating and
tony hawk there's an episode for
everyone though no matter what you're
into the show covers stories like how a
professional art forger somehow made
millions of dollars while being chased
by the feds and the mafia lots of really
interesting stories there the podcast
covers a lot but one constant is his
ability to pull useful pieces of advice
from his guests
we really enjoy his show and we think
you will as well there's just so much
there to enjoy so check out
jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in i-n as in nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
but wait there's more
here's another podcast you should be
listening to instead of mine legacy
media has dominated the podcast world
until now our newest podcast morningwire
is here to bring you the facts to start
your day it's the only daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and leave a five star review
if you like what you hear i think this i
think my podcast has the record for um
including the most advertisements for
other podcasts
and i'm proud of that
but check out morning war let's get now
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we turn to a vile disgusting
scumbag who goes by the name eden torres
now i'm coming on kind of strong right
in the opening but hopefully you'll
understand why as we proceed here eden
torres
is a quote unquote trans woman that is a
biological male um and a trans activist
and when i say trans activist i mean
that torres is a vicious soulless bully
who gets off on shaming and harassing
people and does it all under the guise
of activism
this is how most trans activists work
left-wing activists in general tend to
be callous and ruthless and
pathologically self-centered as we've
seen but all of the absolute worst
tendencies of left-wing activism are
brought together and consolidated among
trans activists
eden torres is a prime example torres
who is a male
went to a sonic drive-in recently now
for normal people a trip to a fast food
drive-through has only one purpose the
most the most obvious one is you know to
get food and eat it
and then pay the price intestinally
speaking later
but for trans activists like torres
every situation and especially every
encounter with normal working-class
people
is primarily an opportunity to make
themselves into a victim and maybe as a
bonus ruin some random person's life in
the process that's what torres uh has in
mind when he he showed up to sonic and
was allegedly referred to as sir after
an employee saw his male name on his
credit card
this employee may have also noted
that torres has a male voice and a male
face and kind of connected the dots
quite reasonably
but you're not allowed to be reasonable
around people like torres and so the
sonic manager was summoned
and the camera was turned on
and the trap was set
and here's how the conversation went
that's why
i mean i'll pull and yeah and why you
want to record me because your entire
staff has been calling me sir
okay uh do you want to park
i why don't you tell me what we can do
now no because i can do the same thing
with you okay but your entire staff has
been calling me sir the entire time okay
what about me looks like a sir right now
okay okay
can we please move to the side no
what
look i'm sorry and i apologize for what
happened
okay if they did that or oh i mean i why
do you want me i'm sorry what else can i
tell you i mean now
what else can i tell you
one if you're uh
can we please move to the if i'm a white
help me move to the side if i'm a white
i don't say anything
okay don't try to put any any words from
my mouth okay
okay
okay
if they call you a sir i don't know what
they did then because they saw the name
on my credit card and they were being
they were not being nice people well i
mean that's what your name on the card
guy what you want whether one what do
you want them to tell you
that has nothing to do with it
there could be someone in the back that
they don't see
that's paying okay
so why would they intentionally do that
can you tell me what your location has
done to be transcompetent because
clearly they are not
yeah this stuff i i just i wish i could
be
i wish i could witness one of these
things sometime i wish i could be there
when it happens
you know because i i would just love to
step in and say hey yeah let me uh so so
here's here's the problem here uh sir is
that you're you're a male yeah you are
do something about yeah fill me go ahead
and publicly shame me see how that works
out for you
so that is that is the answer eden um
they assume that you were a male because
you are in fact a male
and while you live every day
enveloped in your own narcissism
thinking only about yourself believing
that the world has no purpose but to
affirm you these people had other
priorities their priority in that moment
was to get you your food and move to the
next customer
and that ultimately is the great sin
they committed as far as you're
concerned they didn't bow before you and
treat you like the god or i guess
goddess that you think you are
now this exchange with the manager went
on for several minutes and um
let's see how it ended because it's kind
of funny watch this
why does it matter oh it doesn't matter
to you i'm so i mean but to me
i'm a male
okay okay so what are you so i can call
you sir or ma'am what are you
what would you assume looking at me what
are you what would you assume looking at
me
i assume that you're a man
okay
okay
thank you whatever
there's there's a a very funny moment
there that you
that you miss if you're only listening
to the audio but um
eden asks the manager what sex the
manager would assume eden is by looking
at him and the manager says well you
know i'd assume you're a man he was
asked a question and he answered it and
then eden turns the camera around to his
face and i guess we're supposed to see
his face and say well that's absurd
that's clearly a woman but instead the
face only affirms the manager's response
um a response that he gave because
torres again asked for it so you see how
one trap after another is set up the
victim and the victim by this i mean the
manager is baited and baited
all while he tries his best to be polite
and accommodating
but mere politeness mere accommodation
is not enough
unquestioned immediate submissive
affirmation is the only thing that
torres will accept anything less is a
transphobic assault
torrez of course went on to publish all
these videos and tag sonic in an attempt
to get the poor guy fired sonic
responded yesterday afternoon saying uh
quote eden we have a strict
anti-discrimination policy and take this
very seriously we launched an immediate
investigation into the incident and we
have reached out to you via tick tock to
gather more information needed to
complete the investigation
please feel free to dm us here
i just i wish
that sonic said said something like sir
we
we have we don't tolerate discrimination
here sir
now it's not clear if the manager will
be fired but the recent history that
we've seen with these incidents would
suggest that his chances of remaining
employed are pretty slim
a corporation like sonic
they could tell torres to get lost
even better they could condemn his
actions and his bullying of their
employee and then tell him to get lost
but instead they'll probably just cave
to his demands as for the videos they
demonstrate an important point
that gender ideology more than any other
leftist doctrine
is spread and propagated by force
what you're witnessing in videos like
this is a modern form of forced
conversion
gender activists compel normal people to
affirm their doctrines under threat of
public shaming loss of income or
violence or all three in some cases
in a forced conversion centuries ago or
even today in some parts of the world
you may have been coerced into affirming
a religious doctrine under threat of
being burned at the stake
now you're coerced into affirming the
doctrines of the gender cult under
threat of having everything else in your
life aside from your physical body
incinerated
trans activists are basically what your
public school history teacher told you
the inquisitors were the difference is
that the inquisition has been
caricatured and it was far more
defensible than modern-day cancel
culture is
especially the cancel campaign's waged
by trans activists also in in this
inquisition
of today the inquisitors are not trying
to coerce a belief in or submission to
any sort of eternal celestial god rather
they themselves are the gods
at least that's what they believe
and they want us to believe or pretend
we do
all while posturing as the victim in an
exchange that they instigate
with someone who does not want to be a
part of it
that's how the game works and it is
repulsive
and that's why today eden torres the
miserable
scumbag
is canceled with a vengeance
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
makes excuses for protesters following a
democratic senator into a bathroom while
the media prepare a full frontal assault
on facebook in order to suppress
conservative information that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen